there you are my friends welcome back
now before the break you were witnessing
my greatest TV humiliation I described
him as a Donald Trump president Trump
and not to uh well a figure from a
children's television program one day in
the future right in the future this is
true the heads of the justice department
and the FBI will no doubt be brought to
Capitol Hill to testify about the
historic decision to raid a former
president's home you see late last night
Trump's private residence was raided now
we don't yet know too much about what
was in that search warrant but we do
know that the raid concerned the removal
of classified documents from the White
House that Trump allegedly took with him
when he left office last year this is
what Trump said in a statement I love
this these are dark times for our nation
as my beautiful home in Palm Beach
Florida is currently Under Siege raided
and occupied by a large group of FBI
agents nothing like this has ever
happened to a president of the United
States before such an assault could only
take place in broken third world
countries sadly America has now become
one of those countries corrupted a level
not seen before they even broke in to my
safe
so what was in that safe I'm joined Now
by President Trump's former senior
advisor uh Jason Miller how are you
Jason Jeremy good to be with you I'm
sorry about my inability to say his name
um let's cut to the chase how long did
you work with with Donald Trump so I
worked for the president both the 2016
campaign and the 2020 campaign in them
for about five or six months after he
left office quite possibly the most
divisive uh a light Johnson but on a far
greater scale loved and loathed in equal
measure I remind people in this country
that 74 million people voted for him in
the last election now currently under
investigation over that Capitol Hill
Riot uh last week we saw a situation
where Nancy Pelosi went to Taiwan
apparently nothing to do with Biden last
night the FBI raid an ex-president's uh
residence Biden's hand in this or not I
don't think Biden directly this is not
going to help Biden if anything is going
to backfire but I do think that it's a
political appointees that Joe Biden has
put in the doj in other places and how
had a hand in this I mean the fact that
this happened we've never had something
like this in American history this is
what happens in Venezuela or Cuba or
with the CCP in China and we're now a
laughing stock of the world at what
we're doing for political retribution
you talk about political retribution
presumably
um from this side of the pund I would
look at it and go they're doing
everything they can to
prove that he broke the law which means
he won't be able to stand for public
office would that be fair that's
absolutely true that's what we're seeing
with the January 6 hearings that's what
we're seeing with this uh effort with
the uh the FBI agents doing their raid
last nights what we see with the
Democrats on Capitol Hill going after
his tax returns they're going to do
everything they can to stop them for
2024. what a lot of folks might not
realize he's leading in the primary
president Trump is and also a lot of
polls show him leading Joe Biden so Joe
Biden's in a pretty bad place right now
and Donald Trump is setting up for a
victory that's why I think the Deep
State that's why I think the bureaucracy
they're coming after him with everything
they have it's interesting though isn't
it you said to me during the break that
I said is he going to stand I think
he'll stand what do you think do you
think he'll stand because you said after
last night the Republicans are
absolutely raging absolutely I think the
before last night I'd say was maybe in
the 60 40 maybe 70 30 range I think
after last night I think it's almost
certain that President Trump runs again
and I think the reason being is he
realizes that once you start hacking the
swamp once you start trying to change
things they're never going to stop
shooting at you isn't it true to say
that that any candidate that would try
and take that nomination from him would
need his acceptance his support he has
this amazing uh control over the
Republican party but what would you say
to the critics who say he left office in
disgrace I mean I read something today
apparently flushed evidence down the
toilet you don't say toilet
uh bathroom uh apparently there is
indeed the very toilets that the
president Trump allegedly uh flushed
evidence down it just man to man you and
me
it's devious Izzy as duplicitous as
everybody makes out what's the real man
you know the real man I do I think he's
one of the things is his exact same off
camera is he is on and I'll tell you
that's different from any other
politician I've ever worked with and
I've done that for much of the last 20
almost 30 years you always know where
you stand with Trump there's no guessing
game he'll tell you to her face there
have been plenty of times he said Jason
this is great ideas plain to times where
he said this is a terrible idea there's
never a guessing game but the thing
about him going and running I think a
lot of people forget this point not only
does he have a firm grip of the
Republican base right now keep in mind
in 2020 he actually set the modern
record for votes with Hispanic Americans
African-Americans Asian Americans for
Republican best ever since 1972. I don't
think that there's another Republican
that can win in blue States Democrat
States the same way that Trump can does
he demand total loyalty there was
something in the newspaper I read the
wicked it you know he's he New York
Times I think said you know he demands
his General support him it was just this
extraordinary rest sorry I mean again
from this side of the punch you know he
he sacked almost everybody all the time
and yet leaves office okay left office
didn't win made a big thing about that
did he I mean there's so much that's it
sounds a terrible thing to say
fascinating about this man but but if if
you look at what happened we're sat here
and we're saying if there was an
election in the United States of America
tomorrow he would be the next president
of the United States what does that say
about the American people what it says
is the American people they at the time
in 2020 they were told that if you just
stopped tweeting mean things if we just
restore sensibility and a really nice
guy like Uncle Joe everything is going
to go back to normalcy in the world
we're not going to have invasions uh
we're not going to have a crisis at our
Southern border there'll be no inflation
well guess what the exact opposite has
happened I want to go back to a point
that you said a moment ago about the the
absolute loyalty because I I think if
you're trying to understand what Trump
is about if you're in the room with him
you're expected to have an opinion he'll
go around doesn't mean it matter you're
the most senior person most Junior
person he'll look in your eye say what's
your opinion on this position he's fine
if someone stands up and says no I think
you're wrong if you have a good idea or
a solution to go forward if you're it's
easy for someone who works for
politician to say no but if you have
nothing to back it up then he'll tell
you to get lost he's box office isn't he
I mean he's he's one of those people
that as I said at the beginning of our
chat Jason demands 100 loyalty you love
him or you love him so let's say stands
you think he will I think I think so and
if he if he wins will the Call come to
Jason Miller will you go back and work
with him again oh the call will come
before he actually wins it will be to
help him I've already told him that if
he runs I'll be there to help him
absolutely I'm always his number one
biggest wingman and I'm ready to go into
battle again do you think that um the
American people can forgive uh January
the sixth do you think enough of them uh
can put that behind them because we
haven't got long you're right again from
this side of the pun Joe Biden's been a
huge disappointment Kamala Harris has
disappeared out of view so that's a
really smart question because there's
always the match-up are you going to go
with the Joe Biden who tanked the
economy allowed Putin a role in the
Ukraine China just a matter of minutes
I'm guessing until they took over Taiwan
maybe it's by the end of this show you
stack that up against what Trump was
able to do people say you know what we
can go and we're going to pick how does
it impact me in my family that's what
all comes down to the pocketbook look
the wealth disparity uh is still getting
bigger and bigger people the inflation
not just hurting folks here in the UK
really crushing people in the U.S
they're like hey I'm not going to say
that what happened on January 6th should
be swept under the rug it was a terrible
day for America and but the Bad actors
the people who had planned and plotted
this thing they weren't part of a trump
movement a trump agenda he has no time
for the lawlessness and the craziness
those if you broke a law if you
assaulted someone very very quickly
could he have been more vocal in
criticizing and trying to stop it that's
the question surely sure and but do I
think it fundamentally would have
changed the outcome on that day no could
he have spoken out earlier uh I do think
so so if you if he wins in 2024 and you
get a job you'll come back on the show
will you I'll always come back a real
pleasure seriously I'd love to have had
more time Jason Miller that right last
night on on Donald Trump's home Jason
says and this is really interesting will
Galvanize Galvanize the Republicans
behind Trump he said to us just them you
know before last night maybe 60 40 Jason
is convinced that Donald Trump will
stand again in 2024 and judging judging
by what we see in the polls Not only
would he stand he'll win maybe Johnson
will come up make a comeback listen